what has happened to you since our last
episode H well it's a good question I
guess we take the uh the L the long
route in explaining what exactly has
happened here you're of course well
aware of the situation uh you've been
you've been a great friend and a great
uh uh Confidant in uh in this affair but
uh what I can tell you is that uh I am
no longer in the academy as a member of
staff and a lecturer I've left the
academy because I was soft cancelled at
a prestigious University in the UK I
won't say which one I prefer to keep the
details off the table it's uh it's
happened quite a quite a a bit way back
now so uh we'll keep that off the table
we can certainly talk about how we got
there or at least how we got here yeah I
was instrumental at least in some
regards I facilitated your soft
cancellation this is correct it was you
and Michaela Peterson so I have the both
of you to thank for unable Duo of people
to be associated with awful individuals
that try to improve the of others by
putting out content to help them better
themselves gosh you people you know okay
so take it from the top what what was
the issue what was the experience what
were the conversations what was the
outcome well I suppose the just to take
it from the very beginning is that I
went through an application and
interview process for a professorial job
as as I said a fairly prestigious
University in the UK and what were you
at the time what were you I was a
lecturer I was a lecturer what's the
official is that lecturer of or is that
associate professor it's just a lectur
ship a lecture ship or a lecturer you
would uh teach classes more so it's it's
sort of like um a contract based
professorial job at a non UK University
so you would you would be seen as a
teaching stream professor at another
University for
example yes yes so I i' I'd gone through
the process of of this uh job and I did
end up getting it so and the reason why
I know all these details is because it
was told to me by various members of of
staff and um various members of the
hiring committee after the fact so there
are certain people that were very
unhappy with what had happened and they
couldn't keep it to themselves and they
gave me all these details about the
things that had transpired behind closed
doors but just to just to explain what
happened is that um I was essentially
chosen to be the professor I was
essentially given the job but the
contract was not sent to me right you
know this was the decision was made on a
Friday and HR obviously doesn't work on
the weekends so you'd have way till
Monday but in between the Friday and the
Monday one member of of the department
or a few members of the department had
heard that I would be the next in line
for the job and so they brought up the
podcast that I was on the podcast with
yourself the podcast with Michaela and
then it became an issue that I was not a
worthy candidate because of my
participation on these
platforms and so they'd essentially
brought it back to a second interview a
a a sort of Kangaroo Court which was set
up in such a way that it put me to to be
a bad candidate Chris before I even sat
down in that seat for the second
interview they'd already playing the
podcast that I was on with you uh
decrying that I was a member of the
manosphere they they actually one member
of the hiring committee actually uh
circulated an article salon.com article
on the red pill and decried me as being
a member of that community that being
the manosphere
community
yes we spent much of that conversation
for the people that haven't listened to
it we spent much of that
conversation the mildly criticizing to
outright mocking the red pill confus
confused ideas about what men should and
shouldn't do it was about two years ago
when we sat down and it was one of the
really formative conversations that I
had really you've written a number of
great articles about this but yours have
been really really sort of foundational
in my understanding of the the
conception of what's going on this too
world problem imbalance hypogamy all
that stuff but it was
so
overly delicate and and so softly spoken
throughout that we would have been
accused by anybody in the manosphere of
being blue pilled anybody in the
manosphere would have said this is sing
for feminists this is you're you're
you're wanly bending at B breaking your
back because you want to be accepted by
The Wider community at large and what it
shows is just how far the can move that
to internet people you were so blue
pilled that you're a cook but to
academic academic people you're so
bigoted that you're unspeakable do you
know what I mean and it's the same it's
the same conversation same conversation
and the thing which I found most
interesting is that I was told that one
member of the hiring committee was so
appalled by this decision that they
refrain from actually making a call as
to who would receive the job they'd
abstain from voting at at all because
they thought it was it was simply a
travesty which kind of rings true to me
because it it it seems to me I have two
sort of takeaways from from this
experience the first takeaway is that
people have this tendency to believe
that cancel culture is something which
is overt in public that it's a public
cancellation right someone is is a
public figure that is no longer uh
working a job because members of their
faculty or Department have removed them
because of some sort of public
consternation but my contention is that
true cancel culture is pervasive and
Silent it's behind closed doors where
members of The Academy will uh
essentially blackball uh potential
candidates because of their political
ideologies let's say now I would say
that the other takeaway is that I don't
think it's purely based on political
atmus these sort of soft cancellations I
think 50% of it is political and the
other 50% of it is personal I would say
that a lot of these cancellations are
premise around jealy within the academic
sphere Jordan Peterson comes up as the
optimal example I think that half the
people that wanted to cancel that guy
they did so because of his views on Bill
Bill c16 and I think the other half of
the academics that wanted to cancel him
were simply jealous of him they didn't
like the fact that he was courageous and
bold in making a public statement
regarding this particular policy and
that he was accumulating all of the
Limelight academics are very jealous and
Petty people by Nature just based on my
experience you ask any academic they'll
tell you stories about individuals in
their Department uh I think um it it's
often attribut to Henry Kissinger but uh
there's a quote out there uh from uh
Wallace Seer who was a American politics
Professor out at Columbia University in
the 1950s and 60s and he said that the
reason why University politics is so
vicious is because there's so little at
stake and it ties into something called
s's law which stipulates that the
intensity of feeling in a dispute is
inversely proportionate to the value of
the at
stake yes well one thing that it's got
in my head is that personal vendettas
masquerading as social justice or
righteous call out is such a beautiful
strategy to couch your own Petty
juvenile capitalistic personal
egotistical aspirations in because it
gives you it it allows your questionable
morality to stand on the shoulders of
someone that you deem as having done
something wrong and it means that
nobody's actually going to bother to
look at you this is right this is
correct uh I I would say that it's not a
meme I think it's probably correct based
on the studies that are out there that a
lot of American professors are probably
far-left and support far-left economic
policies if for example we were to snap
our fingers and make these individuals
have a substantive salary overnight they
would change their their economic views
they would go all the way from the left
to probably the center maybe even the
right regarding taxation are you saying
that the problem to fix wokeness in
Academia is to pay people more no one
complains when they're highly paid do
they I had uh Corey Clark on the show I
may have sent you that one on uh on
WhatsApp and um you know another skew is
that the academy is now very heavily
dominated by women and women and men
have differing ideas about what is is
and is not acceptable behavior what is
and is not acceptable findings to be
discovered in research how Behavior
between students with their lecturers
and lecturers with each other and so on
and so forth it it's a
shifting uh shifting tectonic plate I
think beneath the academy in a way that
it hasn't been previously uh and then
again the modern world of like leftism
not traditional liberalism but like this
sort of Internet leftism ism
is purpose built to make the followers
look good online it's it's performative
empathy it's look at how much I care
about this disadvantaged group it's the
tyranny of the minority um you know
trying to uphold whatever the most
oppressed this week it's people with a
club foot and next week it's people with
a gluten intolerance and then because
that makes you seem like an empathetic
person but as we've seen over the last
couple of months you know Ellen
degenerous lizo Amy Schumer you know the
most
vehement forthcoming of the like card
carrying we care about the the little
people people are actually the ones that
are the most bigoted behind the scenes I
I would completely agree with that
statement that sentiment in its entirety
I would say that within within these
sort of Institutions it is the
appearance of the thing without the
thing itself and and the the I I suppose
the fr frustrating part though is that
the effects or the downstream the second
third third order effects of that is
that you're not hiring the most
meritocratic candidates the best person
does not receive the job simply because
they don't hold certain ideologies which
are in conidence with those within an
department or within an institution
which drives down the quality of
research if you're not hiring the best
people to do the best the best uh form
of research out there so we are in
essence taking institutions such as the
academy such as the news industry and
downgrading it because of political
ideology because of wanting to look good
we reduce the quality because we reduce
the the quality of individuals that we
hire based off of their ideology okay so
you turn up to this second interview
which actually turned out to be a
struggle session where you were held up
against the wall and had my podcast our
podcast episode shot into your face what
happened after that because that didn't
necessarily mean that you needed to
leave the academy right uh excellent
question I didn't care that's that's the
short answer I think I I'd relay this
point to you is that when this Happ day
yeah we spoke yeah exactly that we spoke
that day and within the next 24 hours i'
moved on to something different I look
I'm the type of person I I take these
sort of things in stride and I don't
Linger on them for very long I like to
move on to the next thing right away and
you know in life you have a lot of
options at least I'm I'm the type of
person that can cultivate different
options and I took an option that was
available to me and um I'm very happy
now to be honest with you I I look at
this particular soft cancellation very
similarly similarly to the Co lockdowns
in the sense that it was a form of
accelerationism because I was always
going to leave the academy at some point
and join the private sector join
industry and they just did that for me
right so thanks I guess I mean I I I
look I have no adamis towards the people
that did it I understand I understand uh
their point of view I understand how
this happens in the academy and to be
honest with you if you're an academic in
uh at an academic institution and this
sort of thing happens to you it should
be expected it should be expected at
this point cancel culture as I said is
endemic within the institution it's a
soft cancellation it's never public or
very rarely is it public the the the
soft cancellation thing is so
interesting as well because it's another
uh layer of protection from the accuser
to the accuse ex that exactly you know
we we we there's no point at which
anyone in HR or some news organization
could come in really where's the story
from like Vincent wasn't allowed to sit
at the cool kids table in the staff te
room you know like where there's there's
none of that it's it's all the easy to
disguise second order wishy-washy
manipulative stuff right I I agree with
that and I I would say that it's a
pernicious Brilliance where you can use
the available machinery and mechanisms
within an institution to be able to
cover Your Tracks to be able to
demonstrate that look I I did all the
necessary things that I needed to to
ensure that this candidate had a feir
hearing I had a second interview where I
had him or her you know say exactly what
was on their mind and answer these
questions but in actuality it's done in
a way that again identifies flaws in
candidates uh manufactured flaws as it
were that makes them a candidate that's
not viable for a job or a position what
were the particular issues what were the
particular issues that they took with
our episode well well one thing was the
comment that I made around um the
ravisher and the ravish so again that
conversation the line of conversation
was around compatibility between two
people in the relationship and so they
made it seem as though I was in favor of
women getting ravished something
ridiculous along those lines I think a
lot of women are in favor of women
getting ravished as well I I don't want
to comment on that Chris because I might
get canceled again that's impossible at
this point second cancellations but you
know that's the kind of thing that I'm
talking about it's it's nitpicking uh
bits and pieces of podcasts bits and
pieces of media without any sort of
context and presenting that as the
person's views on a certain point
without playing the first five minutes
uh prior to that and the mere fact that
I was on a podcast with Michaela
Peterson was also another problematic
issue uh another thing that was
interesting as well I'm just remembering
this right now is that someone said to
me ah you know one of your podcasts at
least the podcast with Chris was on
Rumble that's an ALT right side and must
mean that you are somehow affiliated
with these sort of
people it's just it's just circle
circumstantial evidence that is clumped
together to make an argument in favor of
someone being a a terrible person oh
dear yeah the guilt by Network
Association or guilt by website
Association that yeah I I've it's so
strange man the um and this is the
closest that I've been to someone going
through this experience I said it to you
at the time I am sorry for the for the
annoyance it caused even if it does end
up being an accelerationist thing and it
was you know a blessing in disguise and
all the rest of it the fact that you've
managed to alchemize a shitty sit
situation into a good one doesn't mean
that the shitty situation should have
started in the first place but yeah to
be this close to it for me personally
invested in you as well and your
well-being is so bizarre because I see
these stories on the internet and I know
that they're happening I know they're
not a fiction but because it's never
been me right yet and because it's never
been anyone really close to me it kind
of seems like laughing or it almost
seems like a story or something else
that's not going you know like these
Portland antifa people like it just
doesn't seem like they actually exist it
just seems like they just exist on like
Fox News or CNN or something and yeah I
I I don't actually see them and this has
made it a lot more visceral and real
absolutely personal experience I think
is the greatest teacher I'm I look there
I guess this is a general comment about
reading versus doing things I'm I I
would say that when you're up close and
personal and you're actually doing an
activity then that's a form of primary
knowledge right you have a very good
feel about what something is actually
like versus secondary knowledge which is
something that you acquire from reading
a book you're just reading something
that someone else did right you don't
actually feel the thing see the thing
with your eyes you're experiencing what
is happening on a page so I I would say
that it's it's far more impactful uh and
it's far more instructive when you see
something up close and personal
primarily I'm glad that you went through
it so that I didn't need to learn the
lesson uh me and uh George Mack had this
idea of 2D l and 3D lessons and it Maps
exactly onto what you're talking about
so a 2d lesson is me reading Bill
Perkins book di with zero in which he
says that wealth time and uh Health time
and money are the three main parameters
that you're playing with and you want to
end up enjoying your life as much as
possible which means maximize your
health spend your wealth appropriately
and utilize time as best you can and
reading the book book's really impactful
it's great read it's 4 hours long
everyone can go and listen to the
episode I did with Bill or go pick the
book up it's fantastic
reading the book was a 2d lesson
recording with him and then him saying
hey what are you doing after this and I
was like don't know probably going to go
home and like edit this episode he's
like do you want to come wake surfing I
was like yeah sure I can wake surf So
within two minutes he's made two phone
calls the driver that he had outside
Loops back around the block picks us up
his boat captain jumps in the boat
drives picks us up from Austin 360
bridge and then I get to go to his house
which is the most expensive house in
Austin ever sold was built by the
creator of bumble the founder of bumble
built this [__] Compound on the water
um and then I got to see firsthand how
he's instantiated the strategies from
the book you know he's he's really
utilizing as much as possible to free up
his time to free up his mental ability
so that he can have fun with his friends
so that when he works he's incredibly
focused and for when he has time off
he's incredibly relaxed I was like oh
yeah like I didn't need to read the book
I could have just come and I could have
just had the 3D not the 2D lesson
absolutely I think that's a really great
analogy when it comes to to learning uh
especially in this age is that would you
so just a general question here would
you rather take lessons on how to shoot
a basketball from someone who's written
a book about shooting a basketball or
Michael Jordan Michael Jordan all day
Michael Jordan exactly all day long not
because he's Michael Jordan but because
he's been in the NBA and he has a a long
a long um many years of experiential uh
knowledge on this sort of issue so what
I'm noticing especially um with these
sort of courses that a lot of the um the
gum tree people are developing is that
it's never people that are the best of
the best in a particular area it's
always the people that are writing books
that are selling courses all the people
that are that are doing these things are
too busy making money so you should be
you should do like Nancy Pelosi and just
copy trade all these people or just copy
trade Nancy Pelosi or something because
she's actually doing she's not writing a
book on investment yeah yeah it's
political no not at all not at all again
the the the of all of the lines that I
don't want to cross it's Nancy Pelosi
insider trading that's where it's gone
too far so final final thing now that
you are on the outside looking in to the
academy what is your prediction for the
future we have some close friends Rob
Henderson being one of them uh that are
remaining in for better off a worse
what's your prediction for the future of
Academia 20 to 30
years it's it's no longer going to be a
viable institution because of things
like this happening why why would anyone
why would any parent uh send their child
to a four-year institution soaking up
all this money all this debt for four
years of ideological indoctrination and
essentially not paying for an education
why would anyone subscribe to that sort
of model I mean there was a there's an
interesting tweet I don't not on Twitter
very often but there was an interesting
tweet I read the other day what is one
scam that uh we are uh aware of but not
is not as publicized we haven't sort of
um gotten rid of the scam and the answer
that came up the most was higher
education so what this means is that
there's going to be alternative means
for Education uh not just the university
itself I think the university is going
to fall by the wayside you're of course
going to get top two universities that
remain at the very top but everything
else within the periphery all the second
third order or excuse me third degree
universities are going to be eliminated
or have their their enrollment rates
reduced significantly I would say within
the next few 30 years yeah well I don't
know I can't whether that seems tragic
it does seem tragic to me actually i'
like the antipathy toward higher
education isn't toward the institution
of University and it isn't toward
Academia it's toward the people who are
not using it for the thing that it was
supposed to be for and I try and check
myself when I go like oh you're down
with the universities it's like no no
like the universities are fine it's just
some of the [__] people that are
inside of them this is correct the
institution in and of itself is is
brilliant what it was designed to
educate a ton of people in a short
period of time that being four years but
it's become a degree Mill tinged with
ideology and and um it's it's really
just a business I mean that's that's
another way of thinking about it and and
anything which sort of sets itself out
to be a uh principled but is based off
of gaining money is not principled if
money is the primary principle or the
driving Factor what do you think's
changed in the dating Market since we
last caught up I know that You' had
other things on your plate like trying
to save a career and then find a new one
but what have you been what have you
been getting particularly interested in
in the dating Market well I wanted to
move away from all the descriptive stuff
so the last conversation we had was on
what exactly was going on in the dating
marketplace with relation to men and
women but I wanted to look at it from
the perspective of the future so
examining looking at the current dating
Trends and trying to extrapolate 20 30
40 50 years into into the future what
those results were going to be and I
haven't gotten around to building the
simulation models I know we talked about
that I'll eventually do that but I I've
mainly been looking at some statistics
around um crime violence you know the
young male syndrome as it were and
trying to make sense of all that what is
young male syndrome for the people who
aren't familiar right so young male
syndrome is a concept that sort of
instantiates or says that young males I
guess between the ages of 18 and 30 who
are not partnered not married are sort
of low status or perceive themselves to
be low status they are the ones to
engage in antisocial activity uh to sort
of upend the existing political order
the existing social order because of
their inherent belief that they are
downtrodden in low status right and we
have a interesting Paradox on our hands
at the moment that large numbers of men
within the 18 to 30 cohort aren't having
sex they probably don't have a massive
amount of meaning we have got lots of uh
unemployment in in uh particularly
previously employable groups and they're
probably not integrated very well into
society but we haven't seen an ink kind
increase in antisocial Behavior mass
shootings Etc and this is something I
put to you my male sedation hypothesis
which has actually finally been cited by
bus and William Costello which is pretty
cool
um but you have your background is
actually like criminology statistician
is that close enough I would say so I
would say a data scientist that does
criminology right okay that was close
enough for
me so you are the guy right you
understand the the dating Market you
understand what's going on there but you
also have this very unique insight into
antisocial Behavior criminal behavior
and it's it's coming at it from a
demographic economists statisticians
lens so what do you think like what's
the current trajectory got for young men
and and what's going on why aren't we
seeing everybody blowing everything up I
think we're headed for it I think that
there's a a time lag or delay and I
think the thing with your thesis the the
docility hypothesis that it's correct
but the only element it's missing is a
impetus towards violence a galvanizing
cause as it were I guess that's how I'll
term it a galvanizing effort so I'll
give an example so if you look at um
research done by Scott atrin and Max
Abram so these are professors out in in
the United States I think one guy was at
NYU they found that the vast majority of
suicide bombers in fact all suicide
bombers were male and single young males
are single um the vast majority in fact
all of um uh terrorists were young male
and single if we look at captured
captured Isis records all of these
individuals before they joined Isis were
young male singled single and then they
got married once they joined Isis so you
need some sort of galvanizing cause to
to to sort of bring these docile men to
wake them up in order to engage in
violence and the research on it is quite
it's quite phenomenal I was I was blown
away by some of the things that I was
looking at so I'll give you one
statistic so one study looked at um
percentage increases in single men
within a population and they found that
for every 1% increase in single men
within a population the um proclivity or
the probability of Civil War increases
by
0.25% the the the number of terrorist
attacks increases by something like 0.05
attacks and the number people that die
in terrorist attacks increases by 0.7
people dead and you know again this goes
back to that notion that you need an
impetus to drive people uh towards some
sort of endeavor to Rouse them into
being it's why it's why I think Andrew
Tate and Isis have so much in common I'm
not equating them in that sort of way
I'm just saying that they Galvanize
young men uh towards a specific cause
here is a mission here is a journey here
is a goal that is grander than yourself
you're not useless you can contribute
this is right and you know to to add a
few more points here is that there is a
historical precedent for poyes
Association that is um well polygyny you
know we can sort of break that down but
it's more so a surplus of single uh
young men engaging in violence so one
particular example I can give you in
Antiquity is is um China in the 18th
century so this is H it was called the
nean rebellion of 18 uh 50 18 51 to 1863
and essentially what had happened in h
was that there was a massive famine
there was a infanticide and the ratio of
men to women was 126 men to 100 women
which meant that there was an immense
surplus of men and all of these men that
were socioeconomically poor and deprived
had to defer marriage by around six
years because of this Surplus and I
think 25% of them didn't end up getting
married and this was also affected by
the polygynous practices of the r Rich
so so rich men in haap China accounted
for about 10% of the marriage even
though they accounted for maybe 1% of
the population something like that and
what this led to was massive riots and
and and roving bands of Thieves and
criminals that would go around the
Chinese Countryside assaulting people we
see a similar example in medieval
Portugal where uh I think you know of
this example my favorite one it's your
favorite one so medieval Portugal sees
uh a I think it was 112 men for every
women and because of primogenitor and
and first son rights the firstborn son
was the one that would inherit and be
able to marry which meant that you had a
cohort of second born sons and poor men
that were sort of listless they didn't
have a partner so the the um the
monarchy in Portugal decided to ship all
of these Surplus men out to Conquest out
to Wards overseas so they could get that
aggression out there as a means of
conquest and uh colonialism get the
aggression off Portugal mostly exactly
because they because I suppose the the
leaders at that time knew that these men
were were the the um the lynchpin
towards Revolution and change and their
opponents knew that in order to to to
quickly change the political regime to
kill their enemies to kill the ones in
power they would have to Galvanize these
men to action uh give them some sort of
um Prize or uh benefit or incentive to
engage in political violence which is
very easy yeah I'm looking at this here
uh a landmarked study of 500 high-risk
males in Boston by criminologists John L
and Robert Samson found found that
marriage reduced the odds of criminal
activity by whopping 35% this was
corroborated by another major story of
400 London men who found a 44% increase
in criminal activity during periods when
men were single or divorced furthermore
men who stayed married saw an 80%
decrease in their offending rate finally
a met analysis of the scholar scholarly
literature found a negative association
between marriage and crime in
78% of eligible studies there's also an
amazing one that I learned from Roy bow
Meister so they got men to cross the
road and looked at how far the nearest
car was to them when they did it and men
were either crossing the road in the
presence of women or without the
presence of women and in the presence of
women shock horror it was way closer the
car was half the distance away that they
would do and they were just prepared so
risk-taking Behavior very much is
informed by women and wives very much do
domesticate husband absolutely
absolutely there's a lot of studies that
that tell you okay well Fair off I'll
just make this point is that there's one
caveat with these studies and it's it's
the age in which the men get married but
the the the the overall study was that
men's uh level testosterone drops when
they have children now is that mediated
or is that the case because they have
children and they're married or is that
because they're of an age where they're
testesterone begins to drop that's the
question but I even still I would say
that that's that's quite an important
study with regard to the pacifying
effect of a family on a man and the two
studies that you've mentioned um at
least the criminological studies are
lynchpin Landmark studies within
criminology so Samson lob OG
criminologists have have you know run
the gauntlet in terms of uh great
studies David Fairington who did that
study in London was a former colleague
of mine at Cambridge he's renowned for
these sort of studies and and these are
the sort of studies that that that
really bring the notion of marriage into
uh perspective as a force for um
reducing potential violence in the
future also obviously marriage means
that you are less likely to grow up in a
single parent household and I'm sure
that you as a criminologist have some
terrifying statistics about the
different kinds of crime outcomes and
risk profiles for men boys who grow up
in single parent households versus two
parent households 100% so that's the
second wing of the argument with
relation to Future violence is that
there will probably be a cohort of young
men that grow up without fathers that
engage in criminal activity one study
that I looked at found that 85% of
prison inmates grew up in a single a
single mother household uh you know
General increases so 1% increases in
male figures not necessarily fathers but
male figures within uh neighborhoods
decrease the crime rate by a substantive
margin it was something like
0.5% off the top of my head it could be
lower it could be higher but the point
being here is that the presence of of
two parents within a household is
substantive and Incredibly impactful
when it comes to not just deterring
young boys away from crime but improving
life circumstances so for example single
mother households have $40,000 less
income relative to stable uh two parent
households there's there's rates of of
depression that are higher in single
parent households um graduation from
high school getting into post-sec year
institutions living in poverty you're at
a complete disadvantage if you live in a
single parent household and sort of just
to contextualize this in its entirety
41% I it's either 40 or 41% of children
in the United States are currently born
out of wedlock and one in five children
in the United States so that mean 21% of
them live in single parent households
that is single mother households to be
more specific yeah stagger I had Melissa
Carnie on the show have you seen that
the two parent Advantage it's coming out
in about two weeks time I have not seen
You' love it so she uh she's been on
with Rob um and uh rob ined me to her
book and I had her yesterday dude it's
shocking like she's a policy wonk type
from like Washington
and straight up economics right just raw
economics is what she's looking at and
the outcomes are really really scary and
then you know to fold back in the kind
of social justice performative empathy
line I think that many people
from the high futing institutions from
the
uh parts of government that could
instantiate policies that would be able
to help these people feel like they're
being like they're patronizing yeah
especially minority groups you know this
is specifically a problem in the black
community uh this is specifically a
problem like it's it's not people that
are are college educated if you've got a
four-year college degree none of this
stuff touches you not at all you you
probably won't even get divorced right
the the cohort of the number one cohort
that has the lowest risk of divorce are
college educ educated women yep yep and
the thing is Chris is I think that it's
actually racist in and of itself to to
view these views of these high fluen
individuals is actually a soft form of
bigotry it's a soft form of racism to
look at these people and say well ah you
know they can't get married uh it's okay
if they don't have intact families it's
just how they do things well that that's
ridiculous that's ridiculous I mean
Thomas Soul has has looked at this issue
in in a great level of of of um uh a
great level in in his books um or at
least one of his books white white um
liberals and and black rednecks I
believe I have that I had that mixed up
but he looked at rates of of intact
black families and the success that they
had and it's only when the model cities
act came into effect in the 1960s United
States that we saw a degradation of the
black family structure and therefore uh
increases in crime within black
communities yeah that's interesting okay
so going back to sedation hypothesis
young male
syndrome is it your belief then that the
right galvanizing activation energy
flasho thing could light what appears to
be kind of like the materials the
foundation the Tinder of a particularly
disgruntle group of young men is that
kind of what your concern is moving
forward precisely precisely I would say
exactly that we are one match being lit
away from a massive crisis and I know
stated some examples in Antiquity but
there are modern examples to to Really
implicate this particular crisis so
China would be the operative example so
you you you're well aware of the um the
what was it called the the one child
policy in China uh yes the one child
policy in China resulted in an
approximate uh number what is it it's 80
80 million lost women so which means
that there's a massive surplus of of
young Chinese men that are now coming to
age that are single and what the
statistics indicate is that five there
is a five to six% increase in violent
crime and property crime in China
because of this Surplus um uh uh amount
of young single men there's another
study that indicated that between 1988
and 2004 one sth of the rise in in
property and violent crime within China
was due to the surplus of men between
the ages of 16 and
25 uh here's another one I'll give you
uh I'm just listing statistic this at
this point but um in Mexico for every uh
one for the decrease of one men per 100
within the population there is a uh
commence at 0.43 reduction in homicides
per 100,000 so less men you have within
a population Surplus wise less homicides
you have for the people who don't
understand why when we don't have a
massive gender disparity here like it's
around about 50 50 men to women we
haven't had infanticide because
everybody wants to have a male firstborn
or whatever can you explain why it's the
case that we have these disengaged out
of relationship men if it is around
about
50/50 I guess you're talking about um
the imbalance of women that are in a
relationship and uh the commensurate
number of the the associate number of
men that are not in a relationship this
this by the 50-50 well I think the
reason uh is probably because of a soft
form of polygyny where you have a a
small number of men or an outsized not
quite an outsized number but a decent
sized number of men within the
population that have relationships or
dices with these women who think that
the that they're in a relationship which
means that you have a cohort an
increasing cohort of men perhaps my the
majority of men that are not in any sort
of relationships uh this actually
hearkens back to a historical or a
anthropological finding which was that
we have um 66% of our ancestors were
female something like 70 to to 66 to 70%
of our our female or ancestors were
females whereas 30 to 33% of our
ancestors were males which meant that a
small number of males in Antiquity and
ancient times had sex and reproduce with
the majority of women we don't have as
many male ancestors as we do female
ancestors and it's a same sort of
principle here within the daily
Market yes to put that into a little bit
more easy to understand numbers I think
it's right 80% of women reproduced 40%
of men reproduced it's around about it's
still the two to one but that's within
the overall population yeah yeah so one
sorry go ahead I was just going to State
another statistic but I think well one
one thing I looked at was that um one
Anthropologist found that for every 17
females in for every 17 female ancestors
of ours that reproduce one male ancestor
ancestor of ours reproduced so it's
quite an imbalance between the two yeah
that's huge um okay so if soft polygyny
which is one man capturing the attention
of many women now we're not seeing you
know polycules with just one Dan
Bilzerian floating around but you know
paid woman yes correct in a in a world
that's got casual sex and situationships
and where just seeing each other kind of
labeless relationships going on it's
quite easy to see how one guy could
capture the attention of of many women
uh Lise Perry calls them digital harms
uh when it comes to online dating and
even if it's not that you know one guy
of high value cycling through multiple
women throughout his 20s throughout his
30s throughout his 40s and now I'm mid
40s and I'm finally going to decide to
settle down um can leave a wake of sort
of broken hearts that are kind of left
for other men to pick up which I think
is one of the criticisms of the more
extreme sides of the red pill uh and
manosphere advice which is if the goal
is to kind of raise up the wellbeing of
men a lot of the advice around how to
date women creates precisely the broken
used and discarded women that men are
now going to have to pick up and piece
back together it's it's
a at its worst it's a philosophy that
benefits some men at the expense of
everybody else that's right that I I I
think that's entirely correct that
critique of the manosphere at least the
red pill is 100% correct they create the
problem with the ideology that they
espouse that they rail against which is
young women that are having sex with
multiple men that are incredibly
promiscuous well you're the ones that
are preaching about having multiple
sexual partners that is going out with
multiple women so you're essentially
creating this cohort of women that don't
want to have a relationship that that
apparently use men for their resources
so it's it's it's staggering to me and I
do think that this is a serious problem
that's happening in in modern society
although there is evidence to suggest
that there is of course a fertility
crisis and a crisis around sex where
we're no longer having a sexual
recession as it were I found this is a
uh Alexander daty stat uh he's coming
back on soon he's like I if I could do a
dream round table for dating I would
probably get
you Alex and William with Rob like you
four as a round table would just be
phenomenal to sit you guys down with
enough enough caffeine and and four
hours and a few good mics but he has um
he did a a really really big study um
50% of men aged 18 to 30 say that they
haven't approached a woman in the last
year that's not surprising that's not
surprising at all I I I I'm not even
shocked by that I mean there there's a
Pew research study out there that that
sort of corroborated well actually the
same finding that of the men that are
not in a relationship it's something
like 53% of them 57% of that number
reported not being able to approach a
woman or being afraid to approach a
woman as the reason why they're not in a
relationship oh you need to send me that
I haven't seen that one I thought you
were going to cite the one that said 55%
of men between the ages of 18 and 30 say
that they're not looking for casual or
long-term relationship but we don't know
what which of these are crossing over
the top right like presumably a lot of
the men that don't want casual or
long-term relationships are not
approaching women but some non-
insignificant number of people who do
want to be in relationships are also not
approaching women so you have this very
this is kind of the interesting thing
about men at the moment among like a
million other interesting things is
that you have a culture of guys who want
to you know kind of take Life by the
horns they feel like maybe and Antiquity
would have been better for them uh that
the modern world has kind of robbed them
of something in terms of meaning or
purpose or connection uh that there is
an imbalance and some unfairness going
on and they want to kind of grab Life by
the horns and finally get a
purpose at the same time as being
sedated heavily by porn video games
social media screens weed convenience uh
so they they're sort of pushing and
pulling in in at least pushing
ideologically and pulling in terms of
what they're doing with their LIF style
they're stated and revealed
preferences and then when it comes to
the women thing as well you know a lot
of the time the guys will
uh applaud an Andrew Tate somebody who
really does the forge their own path
when it comes to women and I think he's
got you know a number of kids by maybe a
number of women and he's doing all this
stuff and it doesn't slow him down and
he'll go do this thing but then you know
how many of the 50% of men that haven't
approached a woman in the last year were
a part of that cohort and oh you know me
too me too it went to try and sanitize
men and it sterilized them instead and
all the rest of it I I I don't disagree
I I think that you know the Fallout of
an overly zealous me too movement has
been catastrophic for women's dating
desires completely completely I'll I'll
give you a statistic there they it was
either a Harris poll or an American
studies poll I forget the exact polling
institution but they found no it was Pew
it was Pew uh PE it's always pew pew
found that of of the individuals that
they interviewed with regard to the the
me to movement 69% of men said that it
was Del it had a deletar effect on men's
ability to know how to interact with
women 61% of women felt the same way so
of the cohort that they interviewed
which is supposed to be representative
rep representative of the population the
vast majority of people view the me too
movement as negative towards
interactions romantic interactions
between when men and women because it it
sort of kneecapped then from from taking
the initiative and um asking a woman out
because that could be viewed under the
strictures of me too as harassment yeah
yeah 20% of gen Z say that a man
approaching a woman in person sometimes
or always constitutes harassment and
that's only going to continue to get
worse as people live life more
vicariously through their screens this
aversion to doing anything in the real
world uh it is do I remember I was out
for dinner with a friend and I mentioned
I was bored of him and I said that we
should go and talk to talk to those
girls over The Far Side this is years
ago now um and he looked at me like had
suggested going and like hitting them
over the head with a hammer and dumping
their bodies in the river he's like I
have been told under no circumstances
that I am to go up and talk to a woman
I'm like dude like you
are putting yourself on the back foot
with regards to to dating and and yeah
it's so strange a a such a Hydra head
this sort of generalized risk aversion
that everybody has where whatever the
safest lowest number of potential
negative outcome approach strategy is
the one that's right that's the one that
we should go for because you're not
optimizing for what's best you're
optimizing for what causes the least
number of potentially bad things and I I
I haven't said this on the show before
I'm going to try and thread the needle
but if I'm clumsy please forgive
me how
many how many sexual assaults
actually no how many non- approaches by
a guy to a woman is one sexual assault
worth is it 2 million MH is it 5 million
is it 20 is it zero because there's a
number right it could be and I'm
completely open to it's an unlimited
number no one woman should ever ever
have to face any sexual assault
absolutely and there is no um cash value
of not approaching women that would go
with that but you can see why it's an
interesting question because you think
if you are creating an environment in
which men never approach women I would
imagine that D well maybe it doesn't
reduce sexual assaults maybe it doesn't
even do that I don't know but let's say
that it does you would say okay well
there is it is a tradeoff then right
because if you have a a sort of a
trickle down effect of men who aren't
sexual assaulted not approaching women
who they wouldn't be sexually
assaulting in an attempt to reduce
sexual assault you have this uh
collateral damage with regards to
approach
anxiety absolutely that that's a
phenomenal point you've raised and look
this sort of goes back to our last
conversation and it's all about risk no
no one wants to take any risks anymore
that's that's that's the main thing I
see from Generation Z we're very much
inclined to be on our phones and
scrolling through our phones and not
wanting to go outside starting
businesses approaching people meeting
new people right we have a a generation
of of kids both men and women that are
entirely risk Avers that would prefer to
live life in a bubble maybe maybe Co and
the lockdowns are feeding into this
maybe this is a side effect but I think
this was going on way before that I
think that we're only now seeing this
metastasized and it's only going to get
worse as things progress forward mads
lasson you sent me a paper of his and
he's actually coming on the show in a
couple of months I met him at HB the
human behavior and evolutionary Society
conference a couple of months ago sex
ratio studies suggest that women's
perception of there being few acceptable
Partners activates a polygynous mindset
which in prosperous monogamous societies
drives promiscuity to the detriment of
pair bonding more than 6 million years
of hominine evolution under promiscuous
polygynous and monogamous regimes shaped
make preferences that evoke different
cultural and behavioral responses as
environments change the church's
imposition of lifelong monogamy
contributed to the emergence in the
modern world but if this world's gender
equal societies no longer motivate
reproduction being more open to
could be worth considering as a means
for increasing fertility what do we
think Vincent here we go here we go so
just to break down the argument for the
audience the fundamental question we're
asking here is whether or not polygyny
would be able to end or reverse the
fertility crisis whether relationships
or marriages where there is uh one man
married to multiple women in this case
that would be
polygen uh yes poy would be conducive to
more children being born and I guess we
can sort of bre this conversation down
into two parts the first part would be
well what is the historical precedent
regarding uh polyg polygyny or polygamy
and whether or not it actually is
conducive to increases in the fertility
rate so my contention and I think that a
lot of evolutionary psychologist so your
Amira grars your Robert wries your Matt
Ridley would probably agree with me in
in saying that poyy is actually or
polygamy is actually the norm and not
the exception it is actually monogamy
that is the exception that is the new
fangled uh in invention in terms of the
institution of marriage so just to break
down the historical evidence there was a
American psychologist by the name of
George Murdoch who wrote a very
influential book uh called The
ethnographic Atlas where he surveyed
1,170 societies and what he found was
that 850 of those Societies partook in
polygamy of some of some kind they were
polygamous in nature now the interesting
thing now is that another Anthropologist
by the name of Fran Swan neelsen took
Murdoch's data and reanalyzed it and he
wanted to identify how many of these
societies were
monogamous and so what he found was that
it was something like
21.5% of heran cultures were monogamous
6.5% of advanced Horticultural systems
were monogamous uh 10.5% of hunter
gatherers were monogamous uh 2.1% of
fishering cultures were monogamous all
of this is to say that monogamy is is
again is is not the rule but the
exception just to inter just to
interject there what you notice at least
even in those sort of four different
types of societies is that as the
ability to accumulate wealth and
resources increases increases monogamy
decreases because if you are a nomadic
hunter gatherer type person how are you
going to support two wives bro like the
meal that you eat is what you kill
tomorrow excellent observation Chris
excellent obervation so that's that that
exactly that in and of itself is a is a
fundamental truth of these of these
statistics that the more wealth that is
that is sort of distributed across
society and I guess the less centralized
it is uh the more likely it is for us to
have a monogamous Society uh but but
that that being said just making the
general Point here around monogamy and
polygyny I do think that our our species
is more I say geared towards that
naturally geared towards that in terms
of a factory setting that is polygyny so
uh Joe Hendrick I believe you had him on
the podcast a little while weest people
in the world Joe's great yeah he's
awesome he's a Harvard psychologist for
the audience uh to know and uh he often
conducts studies of his undergraduates
particularly women and he often ask the
question well if you were given the
choice of being the second wife of a
billionaire or the primary exclusive
wife of an average man what would you
choose what do you think in terms a
percentage of women chose to be the
second wife of a billionaire Chris do
they think that their answers are going
to be seen by the rest of the class
let's just forget about that if they did
think that their answers were going to
be seen by the rest of the class it
would be way way way toward the
monogamous thing completely completely
private and Anonymous right
oh I would still think maybe only like
30 to 40% of women would say the
billionaire at an absolute top end I
can't imagine more than that
70 70% Elon keeping out baby oh boy yeah
well that that's that's staggering right
so there is historical president for for
polygamy and there is a modern precedent
for it I think if women were were given
the choice as they are uh today in the
sort in the in the form of soft polygyny
or or soft polygamy and and soft Herms
there is a lot of evidence to to
substantiate uh uh this institution of
marriage well I wonder I it would not
surprise me we have
seen uh Retreats into varying inner
citadels all the way back did I tell you
this one Isaiah belin's idea that Rob
Henderson taught me this is [__]
awesome let me Citadel so isai Belin
says when the natural Road toward human
fulfillment is blocked human beings
Retreat into themselves become involved
in themselves and try to create inwardly
that world which some evil Fate has
denied them externally if you cannot
obtain from the world that which you
really desire you must teach yourself
not to want it in short if you cannot
get what you want you must teach
yourself to want what you can get this
is a very frequent form of spiritual
retreat in depth into a kind of inner
Citadel in which you try to lock
yourself up against all the fearful ills
of the world and Rob explained it in a
simpler way he said if your leg is
wounded you can try to treat the leg if
you cannot then you cut off the leg and
announce that the desire for legs is
misguided and must be
subdued so wow it's like the it's the I
don't need to lose weight these airplane
seats are too a too narrow argument
right maybe some bath water right yeah
so what you see or what we have seen is
an increasing number of different
Retreats all the way back is you know um
I don't need a man uh children don't
need a father in the home to be able to
raise them that is an inoc Citadel
Retreat of I have struggled to find a
man a father who was stuck about after
we've had a child together um from guys
from the guys side uh just hold on boys
the sex robots are coming the entire
mtown movement
um you know all of the sigma male lone
grind set Bro culture all of that is a
retreat from I don't need to be hurt by
other people I don't need to be hurt and
betrayed by friends or by Partners or or
or by Society at large and don't get me
wrong dude I I understand and have
massive sympathy for all of these people
that have retreated into it but I do
think it's important for the people that
are doing that to understand where this
compulsion comes from that this is them
teaching themselves to get what they can
to want what they can get not to get
what they want and you know we're our
own desires and what it is that we truly
feel we we are so duplicitous to
ourselves that we don't even know that
we're being duplicitous right it's
unbelievably easy to make the world
believe a lie if you believe it first
right so uh that's that's an effective
way to do it but you know we've got all
of these different Retreats one of them
you saw with that uh Tik Tok girl with
like the blonde bob and she was wearing
like 1950s uh it's the Trad wife the
Trad wife movement but oh that mem yeah
she even dressed in this sort of frilly
floral kind of dress thing anyway so can
I ask you a question regarding Trad
wives just a straight question what Trad
traditional catholic wife just a TRD
cath a woman is on Tik Tok behaving like
that yeah well that's a good question
she doesn't mean I don't mean that kind
I don't mean that kind
ofal okay you've clarified for me great
so
that was one that one is probably a not
everything's an inoc Citadel I don't
want to make it an unfalsifiable Theory
but that is that is a a recanting of uh
having to be too independent uh having
to make too many decisions and you know
some people may say that that's a return
to a more sort of ancestral form of
living um you've also got one that would
be uh it's bimboism which is the
opposite a similar similar but opposite
end of the of the Spectrum which is
women retreating from contributing to uh
like the earning potential or
socioeconomic uh uplift of themselves by
themselves so I'm not going to go to
university I'm not going to bother uh
trying to get a job I'm not going to
bother chasing down a career I'm just
going to chase down the man it's not
quite Trad wifey because I'm not doing
it kind of In Praise of the man it's
still a little bit more atomized
solipsistic like
individual what it is in some regards
but it's it's there's there's there's an
amount of narcissism in there as well
because it's it's all praying at the
altar of going to brunch with the girls
on Sunday it's not praying at the altar
of I want to make like a cute family
with sandwiches that are cut in
triangles which is like the tradwife
equivalent of this but what and to get
my long Meandering [__] tale to get
to where I'm going is it would not
surprise me if we see a movement that
tries to somehow Empower women that
polygyny is an effective strategy for
them to move into because you have to
create a cultural meme that legitimates
people wanting what they can get and if
what you can get is being the second
wife of a dude that earns 500 Grand a
year MH how am I going to justify this
to myself and if there is a number of
people trying to justify it to
themselves that creates essentially a
market for a meme right we interject
something into the culture this is now
the new Broad
Sigma wies oring whatever I don't know
and then there you go so the mem becomes
reality that that's that's what you're
stipulating and I think I I think that
we're going to get there
so Joseph hendrik was involved in a
Canadian court case this was in British
Columbia in 2011 I think he was he was
also involved with a academic out of
Oakland University by the name of Todd
Shackleford and they were brought in as
academic experts on the concept of
polygamy and whether or not it should be
legalized uh within the the province of
British Columbia British Colombian
government of course shot it down it's
now five years in prison for marrying
more than two people but nevertheless uh
there was a interesting statistic that I
saw the other day that stipulated that
36% of Canadians were in favor of of
polygyny or polygamy they were in favor
of of that form of marriage institution
coming along in the United States I
believe it was another pew pew research
statistic it said that in 2003 8% of the
population was in favor of polygyny or
polygamy and now in
2023 23% of people were in support of
this institution of marriage so we have
seen a significant increase over the
course of 20 years have you I I think
I'll just make one point here Chris I
think that the next major uh marriage
debate or the mar the massive marriage
case it was gay marriage but now it will
actually be polygamy yeah that's
interesting can you work out what the
change in fertility would be MH from a
penous society if you looked at this
because obviously what we've spoken
about is women with no partner are
unlikely to less likely to have a child
uh but not it's not impossible a one
night stand will get you a child pretty
effectively if you time it right
but you have
other contradictory challenges
especially if you're talking about
polygyny especially if you're talking
about living in the same house together
you've got infanticide you've got
poisoning of different kids you've got
uh you know I found this out that a
child that lives in a house with a
non-biological mother takes a huge
number fewer lifetime visits to the
doctor mhm just way less likely to the
kid's ill like n whatever like he'll be
fine he's not my kid even if you love
him like he is your kid seeing raw
darwinian forcing functions are a hell
of a
motivator yeah so talk to me talk to me
about the birth rate change the F
fertility change that occurs due to
polygyny and some of the challenges I
think the literature on it is quite
scattered so there really is no
definitive evidence as to whether or not
uh polygyny or polygamy I guess we're
kind of flip-flopping between these
concept if it does have a substantive
increase or impact I should say on on
fertility rates I always say that the
answer is probably no so the historical
examples that I've looked at would
indicate this so uh a study was
conducted in Ghana looking at um
fertility rates in in 1988 so they're
taking Department of Health Service
records and trying to identify whether
or not uh polygynous marriages equated
to more children than monogamous
marriages and Ghana is an interesting
example because it's it's one of a few
West African countries well one of few
countries on the planet 30% of marriages
are polygamous and what that study found
was that there was no difference between
the couples that is polygamous and
monogamous in terms of the amount of
children had the only mediating factor
that determined the total fertility rate
of a woman was how old she was at the
point she was married so the younger a
woman is the more likely she is to have
women over her her reproductive lifetime
which makes complete sense so the only
conceivable reason as to why uh polygamy
would have a
an impact on fertility rates is because
it may influence women to get married to
a a a resourc rich man at a younger age
that's the only possible explanation but
even still when pob Med uh sort of
accumulated statistics of West African
countries they looked at Sagal Togo
Guinea Niger Nigeria uh and um Ghana and
again they compared the rates of total
fertility between monogamously married
women and poly polygynous um women in
polygamous marriages and they found that
there's no difference in the total
fertility rate between these two
marriage institutions in these West
African countries that hire that had
rates of of polygamy above 30% in terms
of all marriages the difference was
about 0.1 to 0.5 in fact in Ghana and
burino Faso the rates of total fertility
were higher within monogamous
marriages women in P pimus Union
desire more children than women in
monogamous unions however they do not
have higher fertility rates than women
in monog this is correct and they're
less likely to use contraception birth
control that's right so there is there
is no evidence for it okay so how the
[__] is polygyny going to fix the
birthright problem then I thought this
was your golden pill I thought this was
your I thought this was your magic
bullet that was going to my golden pill
you trying to get me canceled again
bro no this is not this is not my golden
pill I don't I it's such a silly
argument to make it's it's it's I you
know what I despise the most Chris it's
when people present public policies that
don't have any sort of empirical backing
or the evidence on it is entirely
scattered and they don't consider second
and third third order effects so let's
say for example that we did Institute
this policy of polygamy we made it legal
and it obviously doesn't work but what
is that effect going to what is that
what effect is that going to have on
crime rates with regard to to listless
men no longer in marriages
it's exactly it's going to be
catastrophic but I suppose we should
turn two solutions we should have a
discussion around that and what we could
potentially do have you looked at any
countries or cases where they've
increased their fertility rate Hungary
spent some ungodly proportion of their
national
GDP uh is Hungary the place that's right
4.9% of their national GDP went towards
family and and share spending and they
did 25%
50% and 100% discount for the first
second and third plus child and that was
discounted exclusively to the woman's
personal income tax or the family income
tax for the rest of time yeah so I I'll
break it down in its entirety so Hungary
was the exact example I was going for
the yot administration is given a lot of
flag but by God do they have some good
policies with relation to families and
incentivizing children being born so
there's a there's something called the
the fundamental law of Hungary which
stipulates that the Hungarian government
must have a vested interest in
supporting Hungarian desire to have
children which means that Hungary in
2019 uh devoted as I said 4.9% of their
national GDP towards family and and
child care spending uh the oecd average
for that for that type of spending is
2.55% of the national GDP so Hungary is
miles above in terms of spending and in
terms of the actual policies they have
one particular policy it was the loan
policy that you're referring to here
where uh any married couple where the
woman is between the ages of 18 and 40
can take out a general purpose loan
interest free and if within the F first
five years of taking out that loan a
child is born the loan continues to be
interest free and the payment is
expanded or suspended for another three
years if a second child is born then 30%
of that of the remaining principle is
taken off the books and it's it's
expanded for another three years if a
third child is born within that span the
remaining principle is wiped off the map
entirely so it's gone and I can list
another set of policies that they've
implemented they they have and you know
actually just to go back to that to
stipulate that the total loan it was
like
31,250 Euros that you could take out
interest free but another policy that
they have is with relation to a tax
imbursement so every family uh if they
have a child can have a tax
reimbursement of 100
96,000 Hungarian foret which is
equivalent I think if you do the the
conversion it's about 550 us every
single year now you know maybe for the
audience 550 is not a lot of money but
if you take into into consideration that
30 37% of Americans do not have 500 to
,000 Dollar saved up in terms of
emergency spending it's a lot of money
and um I think the most popular uh
policy that they have out there is is
with regard to taxation so if a woman in
Hungary has four or more children she's
exempt from taxation until the age of
retirement so she pays no income tax
whatsoever and there's like a 15% flat
tax in
Hungary what did that do to their birth
right it increased it so uh from the
early 2000s I get the I guess the late
1990s throughout the 2010s hungary's B
birth rates or at least sorry the the
fertility rate the total fertility rate
was 1.3 right so it remained stagnant
and flat orbon comes into power in 2010
or 2011 if he does wins and these
policies were implemented in uh 2015 in
2010 when orbon was in power uh the
fertility rate in Hungary is
1.3 now in 2023 the fertility rate is
1.54 so it it hasn't had a massive
increase but it's had it it has had an
increase so we had 10 years of
stagnation 20 years of stagnation and
all of a sudden these policies are
implemented and you see a growth in the
fertility rate there is evidence that
this stuff
works yes however we haven't got
ourselves back to 2.1 we haven't really
even got ourselves close back to 2.1 and
it's cost 5% of global GDP of uh
national GDP so in terms of
interventions yeah Hungary are trying
some things but I think that there are
more fundamental forces play here and it
does seem a little bit like trying to
swim upstream absolutely so just
referencing the the you know fertility
statistics a bit more internationally uh
there was a study by volet in 2020 and
they found that 23 countries would have
their population reduced by 50% of more
or more by 2100 and 34 countries would
have their population reduced by 25 to
50% by 2100 150 countries will no longer
be able to sustain their current current
population by 2050 and this is because
they're no longer having children um at
a replacement rate of 2.1 or whatever it
is 2.33 globally yeah for every hundred
Koreans for every hundred South Koreans
that exist now there will be four great
grandchild it's a 96% Extinction rate
over the next 100 years it's they're low
ones I think um no.8 oh my goodness yeah
0.8 um so yeah we okay we have birth
rate
we've spoken about it before um birth
rate is not good have you got anything
by Way Beyond tax incentives and making
child care more affordable and allowing
people to have loans and this sort of
pyramid scheme staggering thing where
more babies come out more money goes in
what else have you considered anything
have you got any more ideas I have to
think about it more because the the
issue here is doing a research around
public policy and and what to and what
exactly to implement but I would say
that what really will solve this issue
is more of a social investment in
families reinvigorating the institution
of the family because I don't think we
care about the family as an institution
very much and it's the reason why
Society is crumbling if you look at the
Roman Empire for example Brian W Perkins
wrote a book called of rise and fall of
the Roman Empire where he was looking at
well the Zenith of the Roman Empire and
then the collapse and he said that the
reason why the Roman Empire was not able
to sustain itself was because it was not
able to perpetuate institutions from one
generation to the next uh Romans in one
generation were were not able to pass
down the tenants and the importance of
an institution to the Next Generation
the same thing applies to families
within the West today uh we are not able
to to instantiate within children why
families are important we are not able
to pass down the importance of this
institution from one generation to the
next so it's no surprise why there is
reduction fertility rate because we as a
society are individualistic over IND
individualistic the point of atomization
we no longer care about families we
simply care about ourselves and so if
you if you only care about yourself
there's no need to have any children
there's no desire to focus on anything
but your career and how much money is in
your pocket and that's not to say that
these things aren't important it's
obviously important to have money and be
able to provide for the people around
you but you can't spend that money if if
you have no family who are you going to
spend it on yourself yeah you need a
prating culture which I don't think that
we have and it it's you know family is
is totally right this m car book to
parent Advantage you're going to love um
but more than that even before that just
the concept that men and women should
get along that they should be
compatriots or collaborators as opposed
to enemies or competitors or an
adversary to be used and discarded or
avoided altogether you know it it
doesn't from the very very beginning of
men and women interacting with each
other this situation doesn't lend itself
to them working well together so yeah I
think cultural uh changes very much
needed uh individual agentic changes
very much needed but yeah I it's [__]
a role of the dice man it's a real sort
of Co toss about what's going to happen
I mean ultimately it's not an
existential risk right like I've spoken
about population collapse a lot over the
last year it's not a genuine existential
risk it's not the same as like
nanotechnology or bioengineered weapons
or AI uh I mean it's kind of not far off
nuclear war because nuclear war wouldn't
wipe everybody out it' just [__] a lot
up for a lot of people for a long time
yeah so an example actually would be I I
guess it would be like those you know
those Marvel movies where the purple guy
snaps his fingers and half the people go
away that's actually the outcome it's
not far off it's it's just a bit more
protracted yeah but the the thing is as
well like the quality of life for people
the only way that this doesn't
absolutely annihilate quality of life
for people is if we have ai that can
supplant the current
yeaha y That's Right well look that's
what we're headed to I mean I would say
that the only institutions that will not
integrate AI right away are public
sector institutions law enforcement for
example I know working with law
enforcement organizations they're not
going to get rid of people uh
governments are not going to get rid of
people uh they're going to keep them in
their chairs doing work that a computer
could do but you are going to see this a
lot in the private sector where sort of
the needs of people perhaps Healthcare
Healthcare is one certainly
Transportation um delivery services
these are all going to be
right we're not I would say within the
next 30 years we won't have any truck
drivers this is all going to be
automated more than likely self-driving
trucks and
whatnot talk to me about your
perspective on men men's advice moving
forward over the next few years they're
kind of a one of the Lynch pins of what
we've been talking about today you know
what it means to be a man the culture of
manhood masculinity uh and the advice as
well that they're being given what's
your sort of feelings on where we're at
now and your projection moving forward I
would say that the the current situation
is pretty bleak so my view is that the
current advice given to men is that you
should have as many women as possible
level up which is is level up is is fine
but leveling up to what extent is the
question but it's more so engaging in
vapid sexual relationships that yield
nothing in the long term so there is
it's always the advice I would say is
always geared towards short-term gain
but no long-term gain with relation to
personal relationships and what I notice
most about the Rel the advice given is
that it lacks on
right we have a a cohort of men that
Retreat within themselves and have no
interest in in benefiting society and
the people around them it's always about
me me me and if I if I were to give
advice to men in terms of how to meet a
viable partner I would say go to places
where you think you'd meet the people
that hold the same ideas that you do
that have the same values you do perhaps
it's a church a religious institution
maybe it's a a a political conference
where the like-minded are and you be
very upfront and honest about what it is
that you're looking for you can really
only be yourself I know some some guys
in the red pillar like ah he's a he's a
cuck he's he's blue pill that's terrible
advice but if someone doesn't accept you
for who you are they're never going to
accept you so you might as well just be
yourself and see and see where that
takes you yeah a lot of men's advice
would rather you get into a relationship
with someone who falls in love with a
person that you aren't than you stay
single for longer and finally find
someone who gets into a relationship
with the person that you are that's
right whenever you're on it a date with
someone I always find that it's it's
often like the person that you're
sitting in front of is just a
representative of that person you know
they're they're trying to present the
best secretary yeah press secretary just
presenting the best possible image of
that person it's only when you really
get into the third and fourth date that
you kind of realize that this person may
not be who they said they were in the
first date when uh Mr or Mrs press
secretary was uh listing all the Talking
Points one of the things that I've sort
of noticed throughout today's
conversation has been this rapid uh
culture counter culture dispensing of
moving on to the next one of tiny memes
and of of Lifestyles and I think we've
definitely seen that with the red pill
you know only probably two years ago
when we last
spoke it was still in its ascendancy
probably you know you didn't have big
dating panel shows as the sort of uh de
facto manosphere format and in that time
they've ascended and now kind of dropped
off on the back end both Andrew and
trist and Tate distancing themselves
from the red pills saying that it's for
like incel artist virgins or something
and um yeah they they it's it's so
interesting to me how quickly these
things Ascend and how quickly these
things descend on the other side I have
a theory about that and it's it's with
relation to have you heard of the
concept of Lindy yes seem tb's concept
of Lindy so that which is is a
historical prent will continue to be a
president moving forward I believe that
Lindy applies to the red pill manosphere
in the sense that ideas which are
naturally bad so the internal logic is
is is just awful or not sound when it's
brought into the mainstream it
accelerates its destruction so in this
case the the worst thing to ever happen
to the red pill was that it was
mainstream because it means that a lot
of grifters are now going to be joining
this environment joining this circle of
people that degrade the overall idea
because again the idea was subject to
degradation in the first place so I
would say that there's a natural life
cycle to this sort of um content right
there's a natural life cycle to all
sorts of content but I would say in the
next five years I'd be very much
surprised if you still had the certain
I'm not going to name the people why
give them Cloud on your on your channel
but I would I would assume that we
wouldn't be seeing those faces um on
YouTube at least not having the
audiences that they do now I mean Ray
William Johnson was a big YouTuber back
in the day where is he now it's an
interesting one man I I really really
like that idea of of um acceleration
public accelerationism we can call it or
like exposure based accelerationism
where any idea gets molested and
perverted as it becomes way more popular
abs and that means that you need to have
an unbelievably High Purity very very
robust idea at its Center and if there
are any cracks as it starts to get
expanded out those cracks will get
expanded out too absolutely and and I
would just say this point so you
mentioned Tate which I thought was very
interesting with relation to his his
affiliation with the red pill I've
always found him to be interesting
because you know he he's the type of
person that professes to be for men you
know he he's he's all for men's
uplifting and Improvement when he was a
guy that was promoting only fans like he
was running an only fans or a website of
that nature and and he sort of Rags on
men for being on only fan so it sort of
seems a bit hypocritical that someone
that is actively involved in
perpetuating this sort of content would
then essentially be selling the cure to
this content in terms of his ideology it
it it actually kind of ironically enough
mimics a lot of what he says regarding
Co 19 where the same sort of people that
apparently spread the disease are the
same sort of people that make money off
of selling the
Cure you understand what I'm saying it's
very ironic well you also have you know
uh only fans and and webcam girls and
stuff like that are porn so being being
anti porn whilst being in the
essentially the porn IND indry seems
like uh an odd Duality to be able to
hold together I think his argument would
be something along the lines
of that is an older version of me that
was me doing what I wanted to do then or
what I needed to do then in order to be
able to achieve the level of success
that I needed to get to um and there are
cohorts of his fans that are absolutely
have like selective Amnesia about what
it is that happened and yeah no no no no
but that's that's an old version and now
there's like you know the Islam version
or whatever it might be and dude like
I've spoken to Andrew a good bit over
the last five years and you know I've
brought him on the show even though I
didn't publish the episode and one of
the interesting pivots I think that
needed to be made by him and like
everything that he was doing was he
needed to stop pointing the finger at
women because it was getting him too
much negative attention right and you
notice you can go back about 18 months
ago and you will see that up until that
point um a lot of the like finger
pointing stuff he did that um that date
with that girl it's like a British she's
a British girl she does like loads of
different grilling thing grilling things
that's it whatever it's called yeah that
that everyone knows what I mean it's got
like mill tens of millions of
plays and just before that was when I
noticed or round about that time was
when I noticed that the rhetoric had
stopped from being like women are and
women should be to men can be
and I think that that it's a much more
sanitized version of this right because
saying that people can be better is
significantly harder to to see as being
nefarious than like you are like why
aren't you in the kitchen making a
sandwich blah blah blah like and that
that that's a way to sanitize it and
maybe that's an Awakening that occurred
or maybe it was a tactic to be able to
kind of keep the same audience but pivot
the talking it's a shifting of political
messaging I I think that could be what
what it is as well but the the selective
Amnesia thing is interesting but because
it was only 2020 that he was running
these campsites right it's not that far
away I know Co has sort of extended
people's memory of these sort of things
but 2020 was only three years away and
or three years ago and you know I think
with the hustlers University there was a
module there around pimping your the
girls in your life look I'm not I'm not
making trying to make this out to be an
Andrew Tate you know uh criticizing out
but I I I like to be very critical of
everyone and and try to look at it from
a very logical perspective and
understand what exactly people's
ideologies are and whether or not
they're being completely bulletproof and
truthful in what they're presenting or
whether or not it's just a grift I'm
very conscious of of this issue now that
that very famous people are are sort of
getting one over the general population
uh you know it's while I'll come on to
podcasts like yours because I I know who
you are on the camera and I know who you
are off the camera and those people are
the
same
well it's hard it is hard in some
degrees and I I I can see
why definitely as scrutiny increases you
Andrew had started talking about this he
he sort of had this line um that he's
been trotting out for a good while which
I think is true which is the things that
you say when you've got a thousand
people watching aren't the things you
can say when you've got a billion people
watching and I I think he's he's right
in that regard
like kind of the same as the purity of
the idea thing uh you know
inefficiencies and inaccuracies in what
you say and how you put it across they
become magnified when you have a city's
worth of people watching everything that
you do you like million to one odds
happen eight times a day in New
York and this is kind of the same you
know the million to one
misinterpretation happens tons of times
a day if you're the most if you're the
most Googled person on the internet so
yeah I think you
know it would be interesting to see what
the space of men's advice looks like
over the next few years The Washington
Post Christine ember's article uh was
fantastic another one just came out
today uh Politico did a a a was it
called like the men's issue or something
like that and among that was seven
different articles that's nine articles
in total I've told you about
there zero were written by men ah Z well
I suppose I could turn the question on
you you now so what do you think the
future of of this uh this fear will
be
um I I don't think
that Jerry Springer for the Tik Tok
generation can continue much longer
that's right uh because I I just don't
think that there's any there there uh
and ultimately the way that you feel
after you've watched some of this stuff
there is some great manosphere and red
pill content out there and even you know
the guys that sometimes get a bit more
Wayward also have like Diamonds in the
Rough and and and fair [__] play but
ultimately
like your content diet should be
Spirulina for your soul not fast food
for your amydala
and the way that I feel after I watch
some manosphere content to be frank even
if I watch Like Destiny having a debate
with like a prolifer or something which
has got really nothing to do with the
manosphere I like I'm tense and my
shoulders are high and there's a ringing
in my ears and like the back of my head
feels tight and I just don't want to
feel that way and even if you can limic
hijack your way to getting locks and
lots of plays I do think that sooner or
later people are going to catch on the
same way as most people that are
moderately educated aren't eating
McDonald's every night even if it would
taste good like it's food in some ways
but it's also not food in some ways too
so yeah I don't know what the future of
of the men's advice stuff has man like
it's a it's a real [__] Co TOS at the
moment um the choice
between
sedated and
listless or angry and listless I would
rather not have everything be set on
fire but only by like the tiniest of
slivers and the only reason that I can
make that choice is because we're not at
War you know if there was some sort of
enemy force that everybody needed to be
galvanized against just turning the
switch off on PornHub Instagram Tik Tok
and
video games and Xbox and Playstation
would be the best thing that you could
do like all right sure like men are
angry predominantly men have been uh
victimized by this crime what they're
going to do get angry and then okay well
point it point it in the [__] enemy's
Direction yes
yes it's tough to say I mean I with
regard I suppose with regard to the
manosphere and and this sort of um
content the most interesting person I
think in terms of a change or shift for
me has been that sneo character that guy
because he went all the way from being
sort of a degenerate in terms of his
messaging to Now sort of levelheaded in
in what he proposes it's it's quite
interesting because he may be emblematic
of the overall movement of that of that
movement that they they may shift from
sort of the the Goa Jerry Springer
content to more wholesome content it it
is very much possible going from a heavy
metal band to Christian rock I wonder
I've asked this question for ages I
wonder how many of the realizations and
personal growth arcs that we end up uh
relying on are just byproducts of
getting older like how much of it was
you manifesting your reality and I
wrangled entropy and I did the agentic
sovereign individual thing and how much
of it was yeah dude and now you're just
35 like and and now you've got a bit
more time and wisdom under your belt and
it was coming along for the ride the
insights were there along for the ride
roou be yep yeah Neil Strauss uh I'm
talking to his assistant at the moment
about bringing him on the show I sat
next to I sat next to tuck a Max at
dinner on Saturday night um we've known
each other for a little while so that
was cool you know sat next to his wife
he's telling me about his five kids that
are at home and his the problems he's
having with his Lambs it's lamming
season or some he's got Lambs or some
[__] and one of them like got caught
in the kids climbing frame and I was
like this is a guy that wrote I hope
they serve beer in hell and Neil Strauss
Neil Strauss sounds like a born again
like unreligious born again Christian
and Ro actually is a born again
Christian and you know you just have
this you absolutely have this um sort of
Chad to Dad Arc right that growing up
the growing up pipeline yeah yes that's
funny isn't
it natural cycle of of young adulthood
to adulthood and then again think about
the fact that like if you're growing up
you're
you know how the accusation always gets
more attention than the retraction in
headlines it's almost it's almost like
the most effect the most egregious
version of yourself is the one that will
get all of the plays and then the the
milk toast vanilla I've got lambs and
four kids at home version of yourself
has has exited so it's it's like
permanently making accusations for the
more hedonistic gregarious out there
shiny shiny object lifestyle but you
don't ever actually publish the
retraction which is oh and I grew out of
that so everyone's like left with this
open loop of I bet Toka Max is still
slaying puss you're like he's in a farm
somewh he's he's at home blamming yeah
yeah yeah yeah look Vincent harinam
ladies and gentlemen dude I I love you
to bits I'm really really glad to see
you back again uh I'm super excited we
haven't spoken about what you've got
coming up next but I'm sure that'll be
released and made public within the next
year probably within the next few months
to a year um where do you are you
intending on getting back on anything
publicly you're still a digital ghost no
still digital ghost I I thought about it
I know you and I were having a
discussion about whether or not I would
sort of come on and and be a a public
facing person and be a public
intellectual but it just not going to
happen you know with me if I have to
think about something and I'm not
actively doing it I'm probably not
interested in doing it and I think my
writing style and the way in which I I
produce my work just isn't conducive to
this environment everyone wants content
very quickly a week you know every day I
can't do that I need to think very
closely and carefully about an idea and
get it out in a couple months and that I
don't think is conducive to a a um a
long career in this sort of environment
and I just don't want to do social media
kind of just want to be left alone just
to have my head down and and do the
things that I want to do I Goggins is my
man I mean we look we all have a patron
saint in this sort of environment I
think yours is kind of like maybe uh
Rogan you know sort of the podcasting
sphere mine is goggin man you know just
just getting after getting your head
down and doing what you need to do get
back to the lab man I appreciate you
absolutely Chris buddy thank you so much
for having me I love you brother if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe